diferentes países del Norte global están
aumentando sus políticas para devolver
cada vez más migrantes que buscan asilo
en sus territorios la semana pasada la
comisión europea presentó su plan para
aumentar el retorno de los migrantes a
principios de enero Estados Unidos
limitó la cantidad de cubanos
nicaragüenses y haitianos que pueden
buscar refugio en el país norteamericano
para conversar desde este tema nos
acompaña Sebastián Arango nader él es
historiador o politólogo catedrático de
la escuela de historia de la Universidad
de Sergio arboleda y además investigador
en temas de historia en las emigraciones
Muchísimas gracias a usted Sebastián por
estar con nosotros Buenos días Gabriela
gracias a ustedes Sebastián Por qué
Europa quiere aumentar el retorno de los
migrantes y en qué consiste el plan que
aprobó la comisión europea la semana
pasada sí Europa desde el año pasado
incluso antes viene enfrentando una
presión migratoria muy fuerte en
diferentes frentes el primero y más
obvio es Ucrania
Ucrania que bueno con la con la invasión
rusa ha expulsado más de siete millones
de ucranianos a Europa básicamente
Pero además de Ucrania tiene otros
frentes por ejemplo el frente de las
Islas bueno de España Marruecos del
Mediterráneo que cada vez parece más
como una opción menos viable para los
migrantes para cruzar lo que quiero
decir es que hay diferentes frentes que
Europa debe debe atacar o debe atender y
en ese sentido la Unión Europea
considera que una de las estrategias es
impulsar el retorno de migrantes a sus
lugares incluso otros países hablan de
terceros países seguros y yo creo que es
una una respuesta del continente a una
crisis migratoria cada vez más
apremiante más tensionante porque vemos
que esa crisis migratoria tiene
repercusiones en el interior de cada
país en la política interna además de la
política comunitaria
claro y este tema de los terceros países
se ha hablado ampliamente en los últimos
meses con muchas críticas por los
Derechos Humanos la Unión Europea
justamente pone la presión en terceros
países que llaman seguros como Egipto o
como túnez pero cuáles son Realmente
estas capacidades que tienen para
controlar la migración desde sus
fronteras y para recibir a los migrantes
que devuelve a Europa claro lo de los
terceros países es un debate dentro de
Europa y dentro de los países tenemos el
caso si bien ya no hace parte la Unión
Europea el caso del Reino Unido por
ejemplo con el acuerdo con Ruanda que en
su acuerdo con Ruanda aseguraban que era
un país seguro para para enviar los
solicitantes de asilo
y últimamente en los últimos días vemos
como por ejemplo Ruanda se se reacciona
la llegada de migrantes con goleses
entonces
ponen cuestión realmente el carácter
seguro de un país como Ruanda
lo de los terceros países no es algo
nuevo se utiliza se utiliza en australes
se utilizan otros países la Unión
Europea intenta hacerlo pero claramente
estos países terceros
en unos compromisos unos compromisos En
sus condiciones de vida o compromisos o
o tienen algunas dificultades para
una gran masa de migrantes estamos
hablando de Egipto de túnez por ejemplo
inclusive Marruecos se habla también
mire en 2021 a más de 342.000 personas
se les ordenó salir de la Unión Europea
pero de ellas se cree que menos de un
tercio realmente retornó a su país según
las propias cifras del bloque que tanta
probabilidad hay de que una persona que
huyó de su país de origen sea por
razones políticas o sea por problemas
económicos o de seguridad realmente
acceda a regresar a su casa
eso es una pregunta que tiene que ver
también con el con la naturaleza la del
movimiento de personas en este caso
estamos hablando de personas que
realmente tienen comprometida su calidad
de vida o incluso su su supervivencia en
los países de origen
digamos en una parte en una visión
pragmática es sería claramente una
opción Digamos si te expulsan de un país
Buscar buscarla el estatus en otro país
No es tan fácil en materia migratoria en
materia de refugiados hacerlo pero creo
que sucede y lo más común hay una
estadística realmente en el Reino Unido
de Cuántas personas pueden
salen realmente o logran expulsar y es
mínima comparada con el número de
migrantes que está llegando lo cual es
preocupante y nos muestra que el
problema nada que se resuelve vemos
además en políticas migratorias que sean
endurecido las medidas en algunos países
principalmente después de que empezó la
guerra en Ucrania a pesar de que los
países del Norte sí reciben a los
ucranianos hay alguna relación entre la
guerra y el endurecimiento de las
políticas claro digamos que Vimos una
solidaridad y una y un sentimiento
europeo de acoger a los ucranianos como
una sí como una empatía con los
ucranianos que sigue vigente en la
mayoría de países pero vemos que las
condiciones económicas por ejemplo se
vienen endureciendo en países del este o
en países sí como Polonia como los
países con Rumanía en el que cada vez
hay más presión social vemos una un país
muy solidario y que ofrece condiciones
de vida a los ucranianos en este caso
pero al mismo tiempo su población ve
cada vez las condiciones económicas
endurecerse o hacerse más difíciles el
costo de la energía el costo de los
alimentos entonces hay presiones dentro
de los países para que se restrinja o
por lo menos se acote este esta ayuda
que se le está dando cráneo Entonces sí
tiene que ver si tiene que ver sobre
todas las condiciones económicas
europeas del continente sobre todo la
energía de la inflación con la
hospitalidad que el país pueda ofrecer a
migrantes y no solo los psicoanálisis
sino con todos Hay una sensación como de
pronto estamos siendo muy solidarios muy
mientras que nuestras condiciones de
vida se empeoran es una es una
percepción de la población claro por
supuesto ahora otro de los grandes
receptores del mundo un experto en
recepción de migrantes es Estados Unidos
y últimamente lo decidió fue limitar a
30.000 las personas de Nicaragua Cuba
Venezuela y Haití que podrían migrar al
país cada mes si bien Esto estas
personas que pueden llegar al país se
les permitirá tener por ejemplo un
trabajo ejercer legalmente también se
les pusieron requisitos como tener
patrocinadores en Estados Unidos cosa
que pasó principalmente y se le dio el
gran bombo a Venezuela y quisiera
preguntarle qué sabe de la medida si ya
se está aplicando qué ha pasado desde su
anuncio como afecta esto los flujos
migratorios claro la medida se está
aplicando entiendo incluso hay hubo un
un alto número de venezolanos que
pudieron acogerse que se están acogiendo
es una medida para regularizar la
migración cierto para evitar que sea
irregular para tratar de organizarla
pero también hay críticas a la medida
porque se dice que limita la migración a
personas como tú dices personas que
tengan un como padrino un patrocinador
en Estados Unidos un capital que
respalde este esta migración y deja por
fuera migrantes tal vez menos urbanos
más empobrecidos que no cuentan con
estas con estas medidas pero es una es
como un un ejercicio que hace la
administración estadounidense de
organizar la migración y de atraer una
migración que ellos desean que es una
migración de pronto tal vez con mayores
capacidades de integrarse al mercado
laboral de de aportar al sistema social
Pero sabemos y vemos que hay una presión
fuerte en Estados Unidos frente a la
migración porque sí no no Claro Es que
es que le iba a decir que evidentemente
no se está hablando de la migración
humanitaria en este caso porque se
quedan por fuera usted lo estaba
diciendo todos los que vienen
atravesándose el continente entero a pie
y en las peores condiciones y sujetos a
cualquier cantidad de violaciones de
derechos humanos y se quedan varados en
la frontera así es y está y en la
frontera hay una problemática social
bien fuerte política también política
interna entre republicanos y demócratas
y es hasta qué punto Cómo se puede
seguir aplazando la aplicación de este
de este de este mandato humanitario o
Pues que en principio humanitario es
estas estos estos como estas
devoluciones Express que hacen en la
frontera de migrantes que cruzan
irregular eso es un debate que está
abierto entre republicanos y demócratas
biden tiene un un parece que tiene la
batalla y difícil en el congreso
Pero bueno es un tema constante en la
política estadounidense el tema
migratorio un tema de todos los días
Sebastián gracias a usted Gracias
historiador y nuestro analista invitado
en directo a América el día de hoy
Gracias por su análisis